joining me now very pleased to say is
Ahmed Assam he's the chief executive of
Vodafone UK oh my very good to see you
this morning before we get on to the the
rationale and so forth I just want to
ask you about the terms of the deal
because this is envisaged us you owning
uh 51 and three shareholders 49 yeah
your UK sales are getting on for twice
there's and your profits as well so uh
uh I'm the CEO for Vodafone UK as you
know so I'm I'm not here to speak on
behalf of Vodafone group however the
proposed deal would be 51 uh Vodafone
group and 49 uh uh on the three side so
uh it's clearly a deal that creates a
lot of value for both shareholders but I
just can't understand why given Newman
so much bigger a company you only get 51
of the uh the merged entity I think the
focus should really be on what this deal
brings to the UK market and brings both
value to to both shareholders uh clearly
it's a 51 Vodafone group so there is uh
control and and management coming from
this side but it's a creative for both
for both shareholders so tell me about
the rationale behind the deal so there's
uh we believe it's a very it's a it's a
very good opportunity for the UK in
general we believe the deal is very good
for customers in the UK because because
this creates a much better Network a
much bigger Network a much reliable
Network that will be available from day
one for UK consumers both both Vodafone
entries consumers will benefit from a
wider bigger Network it's happened to be
to merge with a competitor to become
more reliable in your words so today we
have a kind of an inefficient model in
terms of deploying our investment we're
all building maybe in the key areas and
with bringing this together it will
become more of an efficient investment
where we can focus more on covering the
length and breadth of the UK rather than
only focusing on the key spots in the UK
so it becomes a much more efficient
investment the opportunity for customers
to get faster Network everybody wants
more data data has grown over the past
five years by 400 percent and it will
continue to rise by 40 every year so the
need for high higher speeds 5G is cannot
be more than what we have today and this
accelerates the opportunity for this it
also accelerates investment as the plan
the proposed plan is about investing 11
billion over the next uh 10 years this
amount of investment will not only build
a world-class 5G Standalone network but
will also accelerate investment in the
UK will accelerate employment in the UK
and and then maybe last but not least is
from a competition perspective we
believe in a market that's competitive
uh and to deliver on this we need to the
third and fourth players they come
together they properly challenge the two
leading players uh in the market and we
get more of a competitive environment
with more choice for consumers and
businesses and the reason for this
increased investment as a submerged
entities because at the moment the pair
of you are not covering your cost of
capital correct so I I think it's it's
been uh well recognized and we've been
quite uh honest and and and and and and
straightforward with it I think the rate
of return in our industry today is is a
challenge uh uh the third and fourth
player we're we're not making returns
that would go above our cost of capital
uh three has been uh cash flow negative
for the past three years so it's not a
sustainable position for us to really
accelerate investment going forward uh
the case that we're bringing together
with this proposed merger would clearly
make investment more efficient as we
deploy where it's needed so I think the
focus should be should be on how we
bring the investment to deliver the best
service for consumers the best service
for businesses and deliver on the
government's Wireless infrastructure
strategy of covering more than 99
percent of the UK with 5G Standalone
which has huge economic value not only
for consumers but also for businesses
now the union is flagging concerns about
Job losses what do you say to them
so uh it's it's very early today to talk
about Job losses but clearly this case
is about investment and with investment
there will be a direct and indirect
benefit from employment clearly we might
get uh provided we get clearance on the
deal and we get to merge companies you
might have some uh roles that might be
impacted and this would go through
proper consultation and proper uh uh uh
process but also there is a lot of room
for reskaling there is a lot of room to
to to reinvest in the network and deploy
resources where it can add value now
obviously there's this issue of the
National Security and investment act as
well this is because three UK is owned
by a hong kong-based company is that
going to be an issue in your view in my
in my opinion we take security
procedures very seriously and as a
business that's regulated and managed by
the Telecom security regulation in the
UK and also we respect customer privacy
we take this very seriously I can tell
you that within our business only
customer vetted teams would have access
to secure details so in some cases not
even myself or my group CEO would have
access to such information both
businesses today are operating in the UK
both businesses are subject to the same
regulation we will need to go through
the National Security process as as we
go through it but we're quite confident
that we have a strong case and we have
strong compliance when it comes to
security Now this will take the market
from four players to three are you
expecting a lengthy competition
investigation
so I cannot speak on behalf of the com
the CMA on this front but I have to say
we need to look to the market in a
realistic way uh what this deal is
proposing and what it's bringing is
really a third big Challenger to add to
the competition of the two big markets
the two big companies in in the market
so it's really we need to see it as it's
not four to three it's actually two to
three but then we also need to remember
then around one in four customers in the
UK are buying mobile connectivity from
operators and providers who don't own
their own network so you have the likes
of some of our competitors within the
mobile virtual space and one in four
customers would go there so the market
is quite competitive today and will
remain competitive what this deal brings
is it actually elevates the quality of
the network it brings a third strong
Challenger in the market for even our
more possible Partners within uh
providers who do not own their Network
to have access to another third
competitive Network